[MUSIC]
>> Hello, and
welcome to our conference call,
MBA Admissions Insights: Preparing for
Your Letters of Reference and Essays.
Thank you for joining us.
My name is Allison Davis.
I'm Associate Director in
the MBA Admissions Office.
I'm joined by Derrick Bolton,
Assistant Dean for MBA Admissions.
>> Hey, everybody.
>> In the next 30 minutes,
we'll be talking about what to keep in
mind as you prepare your essays and
approach recommenders for
your letters of reference.
We'll start by briefly reviewing
the requirements for both, and
offer some tips along the way.
We'll also discuss some questions that
you may find useful to ask yourself
at this stage in the process and
how you might go about answering them.
We'll wrap up by answering some of
the questions submitted by you in advance.
Let's start with essay requirements and
tips.
The requirements, word length,
formatting, etc., for the essay
questions are all on our website and
you should definitely read all of them.
But it could be useful to
review the basics again here.
There are two personal essays, essay one
is what matters most to you and why.
This is a pretty fundamental question
that really invites self-examination and
self-reflection.
Derrick, what sort of things
are we looking for there?
>> I think when you said personal essays,
you said more than you even intended to,
because they're not intended
to be professional and
that you're speaking about work topics.
But truly a personal
reflection on the people,
on the experiences, on the situations
that have influenced you.
And more important how those
have shaped your perspectives,
not just about what your accomplishments
are, what you've achieved.
We'd say focus on why,
rather than focusing on what.
>> Second essay question is pretty broad,
it's why Stanford, and
how will earning your MBA at Stanford
enable you to realize your ambitions?
What are we looking for there, Derrick?
>> I think if you look back over
the decade, 15 years that I've been in
this role, we used to ask a question
that was really specific,
tell us about your short-term goals,
tell us about your long-term goals.
Why would an MBA help you and then why
do you want the MBA from Stanford?
Over time,
we've shifted toward a broader question
because we didn't want to lock
applicants in unnecessarily.
It wasn't something we were using in
assessing viability as candidates.
So we said, what's a question that
will actually help the candidate?
We want you to reflect on why you want
this graduate education in management,
how it's going to help you in
realizing your objectives, and
really thinking about the distinctive
opportunities you'll pursue at Stanford.
Because once you get here, you get I
think overwhelmed by the sheer number of
choices in front of you, so it's
helpful to do some reflection upfront.
>> I think I'd even heard you say
sometimes students have actually
held on to their essays and posted them
on their mirror and that kind of thing.
>> Put them on the door
of your room at Schwab or
at Highland Hall and everyday,
it's a reminder of why you're here and
what you want to take
away from the experience.
But I think that gets back to the point,
again, that they're personal essays.
They're meant to be valuable to
the applicant who is writing them.
There are no shortcuts here.
So you really have to think carefully
about who you are, about the experiences
that have shaped you, and
about where you want to go from here.
>> In general, I think our advice is
keep it simple, don't over think it.
Be sure to actually answer
the questions we're asking,
follow directions, that sort of thing.
What else?
>> We're talking about essays and
letters of reference today and
at their simplest form,
both of those are stories.
I think what you're trying to do with
the essays is to tell a story that
only you can tell.
It should be fresh versus being packaged.
You know what I mean by that, and
we can tell the difference
when things are inauthentic.
One of my favorite alums, Leo Lindbeck
always said, think of the admission
process not as a marketing activity where
you're trying to look at someone and
deliver exactly what they want, But
to look at it as an accounting activity,
where you're looking inside and
then trying to express that clearly.
I think that's a good shorthand for
me of what the aim is of the essays.
I hope that candidates are reading
what we said on the website because
we do encourage people to get feedback.
It's helpful to get a sense from people
who know you very well on whether
the essays are coming across
in your voice, whether this is
the brother that I know or this is the
wife that I know coming through on paper.
But I'd caution you to
think carefully about the difference
between feedback and coaching.
>> Can you say a little bit more
about that, the difference?
>> I think feedback is, you've,
you've done the reflection,
you've done the thinking,
you've put in the effort and
you're getting consanguinity checks from
people who really know you to ensure that
what you're putting on paper is authentic,
but it does reflect you.
>> Right.
>> That's a couple times, that's one or
two times, that's not many,
many hours of people giving you
wordsmithing, and rearranging
your flow of your topics, and telling you
what Stanford wants, that kind of thing.
>> Let's go on to letters
of recommendations.
Again, all the requirements
are on our website,
including the questions that we are asking
your recommenders, so of course,
you're going to want to
take a look at that.
There are two letters of
reference that are required.
The first one would come from a current,
direct supervisor at work or
as we say, next best alternative,
there are certainly situations where
you may not be able to get a reference
from your current direct supervisor.
You might be self -mployed or
working at a family business or
in a new position where your supervisor
really doesn't know you well yet, or
maybe you can't even tell your
employer that you're applying.
If you can't get one from your current
direct supervisor, what would be,
Derrick, other alternatives?
>> I think this is probably
the most commonly asked question at
information sessions.
The short answer is use your best
judgement because you're going to know far
better than we who are good
choices to provide that insight.
But I would think, if you're working in
a services firm, it could be a client.
If you work in a sales role,
it might be a customer, if you have
extensive operations with management,
it could be a previous manager and
direct supervisor, or
a portfolio company you've worked with.
Someone you work with at your organization
who has direct exposure to you and who
cares enough about you to make the time to
write a detailed and thoughtful letter.
But I think you're trying to get,
as Allison said, the next best alternative
means as close to that current
direct supervisor as possible.
>> The second reference actually
has a lot of flexibility for you.
You really have four different
choices here for the second reference.
It could be again, another
supervisor or a peer and
those could come from the workplace.
Or it could be someone from outside
the workplace who's perhaps worked
with your or supervised you in
an extracurricular activity.
Those four quadrants are what
you have to choose from.
In general though,
Derrick, would you say we,
the strongest reference typically
come from the work place.
>> Absolutely, I think, again,
with thousands of applicants,
each person's situation is unique.
But in most cases, what we've observed
is that the recommender who's
worked with you for 40 or 50 hours
a week for six weeks, or six months,
or three or four years,
has deeper insight into your strengths and
your areas of development, than someone
who sees you in a volunteer activity for
a few hours a week,
even if it's a sustained commitment.
So, you just have to be careful
in thinking about those choices.
We are kind of on your side as applicants
when we're reading the applications,
so it's not that we're going to look and
say this really doesn't give
us what we're looking for.
But I do see files every year
where I read it and say gosh,
the recommender really
let this person down.
>> All right,
let's talk a bit about how somebody
would go about choosing their
recommenders, advice about that, Derek.
>> Sure, well, this brings me back to
my point earlier that both essays and
recommendations are stories.
Essays are stories that you're telling us,
and recommendations are stories that
others are telling us about you.
The reason that we ask for references
in addition to the essays is that
others see things in you that
you may not see in yourself.
And so it's really helpful for us to have
both those perspectives as we're trying to
understand you a little bit better.
You can see exactly what
we're asking the recommender.
So, I strongly encourage anyone who's
applying to go to the letter of reference
page on our website, to look at the
traits, the competencies that we're asking
the recommenders to assess, as well as
the three questions we ask them to answer.
But I suggest someone who can provide,
at a tactical level, detailed anecdotes,
who can give examples, who's excited
to write a letter for you and
will actually spend sufficient
time to write a thoughtful letter.
At a more philosophical level,
pick someone who is
in a position to see how you've developed,
who cares about your career,
and who is rooting for you to succeed.
>> I think sometimes,
as you're approaching a recommender,
the conversations that
come out of even asking
them to write a recommendation,
can really be constructive conversations.
>> In a lot of ways, one of
the things you hear us say, Allison,
you know this, but Candace may not.
We often say that we're looking for
candidates for
whom success has been
a byproduct rather than a goal.
And that notion of byproduct and
goal comes to mind as I think
about references as well.
Because in a lot of ways, the goal of the
recommendation could be to have a great
conversation with your recommender,
to talk about your experiences and
to talk about things that you've done
well or areas that you may need to grow.
And to get that person's feedback
on those experiences, and
if that conversation is a productive
one for you and for the recommender,
the byproduct of that is a great letter of
recommendation that he or she turns in.
So, I think it's great to sit
down with your recommender,
this is not an activity that
I'd say simply register him or
her and then make sure the person
turns it in by the deadline.
No, no, no, I think you actually
do want to invest a little more.
Sit down over coffee,
or tea, or champagne,
whatever the situation might be, and have
a good, kind of coaching conversation.
And I think it can be beneficial, whether
or not you even apply to business school.
>> What about,
we often hear applicants worry about
if they approach the recommender at work,
that sometimes the recommender will say,
well, why don't you draft it for
me, and I'll sign it?
What should people do in that situation?
>> Yeah, and
I know that's a tough situation, actually.
When I was applying to business
school last millennium,
I had a manager who felt strongly that
every consultant in the firm who asked him
to write a recommendation should
draft it on his or her own.
So I ultimately ended up
picking someone else.
The goal here, I'll reiterate, is to get
insights about you from someone else, and
if you were drafting the recommendation,
then I think it defeats the purpose.
You end up kind of doubling down on
the things that you already know
about yourself, whereas
the recommenders should be providing
insights that may be new to you and
hopefully may be new to us.
Yeah, that's it.
>> Okay, let's move on to talking
about some of the questions that you,
as prospective applicants,
might be asking yourselves as you
get ready to write your essays and
approach those recommenders.
You will find that answering
these questions for
yourself now could really save you some
time later in the application process.
So, one question you should be asking
yourself is, do I actually have time
to do all that thinking and reflecting and
self-examining before I write my essays?
>> Yeah, but
I think there's no shortcut here.
We're looking for a holistic view of you,
the applicant, as a person, your values,
your passions, your ideals, your
experiences, your hopes, and your dreams.
And our goal is to understand
what motivates you and
how you've become the person that
you are today, and then, again,
how Stanford can help you in terms
of realizing your ambitions.
And so I think you just have to
be prepared to think a lot and
then write, and for each person,
it will be different.
For one person,
it might be a morning run where you kind
of find some time to clear your head.
For another person, it might be the subway
ride to and from the office, but
there's no shortcut here, so you really
do have to put in that time to think.
>> So Derrick,
you had talked about how the essays and
recommendations are stories.
So another question people
should ask themselves is,
what is a story that only I can tell?
>> Mm-hm, and I think that what makes
the story that only you can tell
is not the person, or the event, or
the situation that you're talking about.
But how that has affected you and
how that's shaped your outlook,
your perspective, your choices.
So I'll reiterate what I say on
the road all the time, which is,
don't worry about standing out.
You never know what other
applicants are sharing with us.
I think differentiation occurs naturally,
if you concentrate on telling us who you
are, and
no one can know that better than you.
What I see happen all
the time with applicants,
especially applicants
who have the fortune or
misfortune of being in large communities,
where there are many people applying,
is that they will lose faith in
themselves throughout the process.
And so start comparing, my GPA is
two-tenths of a point lower than hers,
and he was promoted three
months ahead of me.
And it's easy to get focused
on all the little aspects,
where someone may have
done better than you.
But we're reading the application,
looking for strengths, and so
I just want to reiterate that we
want candidates to really have faith
in yourselves, have some confidence
as you go through the process.
Think about the essays as
conversations on paper.
>> Well, have confidence and
faith in yourself, and
don't compare yourself to other people.
That's good advice not only for writing
applications, [LAUGH] but good advice for
life, I think.
>> Honestly, I think the application
process, if done correctly,
is great in terms of pulling
candidates up from working so
hard on their daily goals and
asking some more fundamental
questions that'll be helpful in whether or
not they apply to business school.
>> So,
another question to ask yourself is,
how will Stanford help me turn
my dreams into a reality?
>> Mm-hm, well, I guess the key there is,
do you have some dreams?
Do you have some sense of focused
interest of what you want to do after
business school?
I think Stanford's a really magical place,
and
if you come here with something in mind,
you can take advantage of
all the resources at the university,
from business school to engineering,
or law, medical school, whatever it is,
to make your dreams happen.
But, have some ideas of what you best
self would be after Stanford and
related goals for your education here.
You don't need to make them up,
by the way.
If you don't have really specific goals,
there's a reason that we
can put the goals themselves as kind of
a tweet, a text box in the application.
Whereas the essay is focussed on how
you're going to maximise your experience
and make the most of
your time at Stanford.
>> Okay, well let's move on now
to questions that the applicants,
I'm sorry, that the audience,
we hope you'll be applicants, but
that the audience have
submitted in advance.
What kinds of information should
I be providing to my recommender?
>> I think that's going to depend on
your relationship with your recommender.
I've seen candidates who provide
the entire application and
essay to the recommender.
And I've seen candidates who
simply sit down with him or
her and talk through the process.
You don't have to worry that every single
part of your application makes it look
like you've been lined up since birth
to be admitted to business
school at Stanford, right?
Life is messy, we understand that.
Not all of your choices will make
sense as you're making them.
But our hope is, again, that when
you look back on them, you're able
to extract some common themes and
kind of connect the dots as you look back.
But again, it's not like you have to
ensure that every single thing that
your recommender says is perfectly aligned
with every single thing that you say.
So I don't think you have to go
overboard on providing information, but
again I'll reiterate,
there's benefit to you,
as an applicant, from sitting down and
talking with your recommender,
who is a person who knows you well,
a person who cares about you and
who's opinion you value, about your
performance and about your future.
>> Is it ever worth it to submit an
additional letter of recommendation beyond
the two that we asked for?
Yeah, well, Allison, you've been through
our admission committee discussions many,
many times as we think about what
the requirements are for an application.
So we have asked for
two recommendations because we think
that is the most helpful
across our applicant pool.
We do, however, give candidates a bit of
flexibility on what they're providing, but
it's a risky move.
Right, so, if you, for example, give us
a third recommendation, first of all,
I can't guarantee that we'll read it,
because it really depends on when it gets
submitted, but let's say it was submitted
with your application at the time
you applied and we read that, well, the
question from the reader is going to be,
this is a helpful recommendation or
an unhelpful recommendation?
If its helpful, then i'm going to say,
why was it not one of the two
other recommendations.
If it's unhelpful,
I may ask why is it submitted at all?
It's not a risk free move, because it does
call into question the self awareness and
judgment of the candidate.
And frankly,
there's also an issue around fairness.
I kind of think of the admission process,
it's almost like when you take a test,
you turn the test in at a certain point,
and then it gets graded, and
then we set the curve, and
then you get the grades back.
Well, providing extra letters of reference
is, in a way, like giving someone a chance
to do extra work on a test or to change
the answers after it's been turned in.
That's not exactly fair to
all the other candidates.
So, we'll always try to get
applicants flexibility, but
I do think that they have to
think very carefully about it.
>> Yeah, and I should add that it will
certainly be added to your application
in terms of what do we do with it.
But, as Derrick said,
it may not be read depending on
if we've already read your application,
or where we are in the process.
>> Again, it's like taking a test.
>> Yeah.
You turn it in.
>> Once the first persons grade your test,
we're not going to keep adding and
letting you change
the answers on it after that.
>> Right.
We talked about how the second
recommendation can come from a supervisor,
or next best alternative, or a peer.
So, Derrick,
can you talk a little bit about what
counts as a good recommendation from a
peer, as opposed to one from a supervisor?
And, again,
we're talking about that second reference.
>> Mm-hm.
The reason that we think a peer
can be helpful in the first place
is that most of you will spend
your careers after business school
leading without authority,
in a lot of cases.
You're always, basically, trying to move
the organization, or your department, or
your team, or whatever it is,
probably a level ahead of whatever your
actual job responsibilities are,
whatever your actual title is.
And so, peers are folks who
influence without authority, right?
And so, someone who can give us insight
on what it's like to work with you very
closely, elbow to elbow, shoulder
to shoulder, can be really valuable
in understanding how you'll participate
as a member of our community,
which is a very strong, pure learning
community, as well as giving us a sense of
areas where you'll want to
develop as a student and
strengths that you'll draw upon
once you're an alumnus or alumna.
>> Okay, here's another question.
Both of my supervisors speak
English as a second language.
If they're not able to write as
eloquently as a native English speaker,
is that going to affect my candidacy?
>> Mm-hm.
And, short answer would be no.
We are, with apologies to vegans,
looking for a steak, not the sizzle.
If it's a real
drawback for the recommender, then he or
she could submit the recommendation and
have it translated.
And we just would ask for
the original as well as the translation.
We don't want the translation done
by the applicant, by the way.
So if someone else was in a position to
do that translation, then we'd ask for
that persons contact information as well.
But no, we are able to extract from
recommendations the basic premise
that's coming through the recommendation,
how the applicant has performed and
what makes him or
her successful in a role.
It really won't come down to word choice
or things that are particular nuanced,
is my sense.
>> Okay, so it's really the content.
It's not the syntax, or the, yeah.
>> It's the gist of it.
>> Right.
>> The.
>> Derrick, what's your opinion of
using an academic reference
versus a professional reference?
>> When we think about references for
Stanford,
we're looking at them
as a way to understand
ways that you've demonstrated leadership
and understand your leadership potential.
And so, in most cases, academic references
have not had the opportunity to
see candidates demonstrate leadership.
Again, there are obviously exceptions.
Maybe you've been a teaching assistant for
a professor.
Maybe you've done a research project for
him or her.
And so, that faculty member would
be able to provide some detail,
anecdotes, or evidence.
But for the most part,
when we see academic references,
they tend to be very brief,
they tend to be generic and sad to say,
in a lot of cases, they talk about the
faculty member than about the candidate.
If you're a college senior and
you're applying for a deferred admission,
then the academic reference may be
the only choice that you have, so
we see them more frequently for folks
who are applying for deferred enrolment.
And in those cases, obviously, we know how
to calibrate them, but just be careful.
This applies to anybody but be thoughtful
and careful as you're thinking about your
reccommender to ensure that here she
is able to address the specific traits,
the competencies, the characteristics that
we're asking on the recommendation form,
and in the questions.
And, again,
I'll suggest looking at those on the
website before picking your recommender.
Because if we get a form that says no
basis for judgement for 85% of the things
that we are asking, well, that doesn't
help you and it also doesn't help us.
>> Okay, how about for reapplicants?
What's the expectation for
letters of rec and essays?
I mean, is it going to seem weird
that what matters most to you,
which is such a fundamental topic changes
significantly from the year before?
>> Our view has been that as a
reapplicant, you're evaluated on the basis
of your new application in the context
of the new applicant pool.
There are sister institutions of ours
that will say, you applied before.
Tell us what's changed since the last
application and we don't do that.
It always felt to me that asking that
question came from an understanding that
my last decision was correct.
So, please explain to me what's changed
to change my decision and the realty at
Stanford is that there's so many qualified
candidates that we're simply not able to
admit all of the wonderful people
we'd like to admit each year.
So I don't ever assume that simply because
someone applied was admitted that,
that was the correct decision, but there
was something a mess with the application.
All that to say, you can turn in the exact
same application in two different years.
And I think you could get different
results not because you've changed, but
because the applicant pool has changed.
But it's what matters most to you and
why it has changed dramatically over
the course of, in previous eight or
12 months, then the topic should change.
And if it hasn't changed, then it
should remain similar to what it was.
But I would definitely take advantage
of the opportunity to provide updated
references, because my assumption is most
of our candidates, most of you are getting
stronger with time as you are building
experience and exposure and so recommender
today would be better than a recommender
who had exposure to you 12 months ago.
So, just making sure that
you take advantage of that.
>> I would add that even if the topic
is the same, probably your perspective
on it has changed with another year or
two of life and working experience.
>> And as the coda, I will say that we do
not compare your previous application to
your current application.
So as the assistant dean of admission,
I would look at both applications
at the point that the file
gets back from the interview.
And that's not looking at
it to compare word for
word what was this application versus the
last one, but looking was there some major
red flag that we saw the last time and
wasn't addressed this time.
But for the most part, it's not going to
make a difference in my decision and
I would be the only person in the entire
admissions office who would have access to
the old applications.
So, it really is a new application on its
own merit in the context of the new pool.
>> How about client recommendations for
people in client service businesses?
Are there common mistakes or
are there ways that they can be enhanced
that applicants should be aware of?
>> I think it kind of
depends on the client.
It depends on how familiar he or she is
with recommendations to graduate school
and with business school in particular.
So we have on our website, a podcast,
I think and definitely a transcript of
the podcast where we talk about
what makes a recommendation sing.
Like what really brings
a candidate to life?
And so if you're asking a client who this
may be the first recommendation ever,
then you might want him or
her to take a look at that transcript.
I think it would be helpful, but
I was just reiterate to the client,
just as I would reiterate to anyone else.
How important the recommendation
is in the process and
I would be really grateful to him or her
for making the time to write the letter.
>> There's so many good questions here,
but I think we really only have time for
one more.
Should the letters of recommendation and
essays compliment each other or
should they emphasis different
things about the candidate?
>> I don't say, there's no should.
Sometimes, we see letters of reference and
essays that are reinforcing.
Sometimes, we see where those
provide different insight.
Sometimes they help us reinterpret
things we've seen, but
it's always helpful in context and
as you're looking at the applicant
holistically to have those perspectives.
>> Well, we're almost out of time.
If you didn't get your
question answered today,
please feel free to contact our office
by email or phone to ask your question.
>> Before we go, Derrick,
any words of advice for
our listeners today in terms of
the letters of rec and the essays?
>> Gosh, well, first, I'd say,
you're putting yourself in a great
position by tuning in for the call today.
We have information sessions on campus
here at Stanford on typically Mondays and
Fridays.
We have off-campus sessions
happening all around the world.
I'm literally flying out in about
30 minutes for New York where we'll
be hosting sessions later this week and
then I'll be in India next week.
So we have sessions happening all
around the world and our goal in
traveling to where you are, as applicants
is to be able to answer questions.
So feel free to sign up for those and try
to come and meet some of our alumni and
students, and learn more about
the program, and about the process.
I'll reiterate that comparing
yourselves to each other can be bad for
your morale,
as you go through the process.
We really do look at every
candidate asking yourselves,
what are the reasons to admit this person?
So, it really is focused
on your strengths.
And so, I'll reiterate to you as
candidates who cares about the things that
you're not so great at.
We care about the things that you are
great at and please tell us about those.
Your recommenders will tell us about
those and that's how we make decisions,
ultimately.
>> Great advice, Derrick.
Thank you and thank you to all
of you out there for joining us.
There are two more MBA Admissions
Insights, conference calls coming up.
Being a Great Applicant on August 10th and
Considering a Joint or
Dual Degree on August 31st.
You can register for them on our website.
An audio recording of each of these
conference calls including the one today
will be posted on our website
in the next few weeks.
The current application is
now available on our website.
There are three application deadlines.
September 21, January 10 and April 5.
As Derrick said, there's lots of ways to
learn more about our program in terms of
information sessions.
We do honor off campus as
well as on our website,
you'll find videos of webinars and
a calendar of events and audio recordings.
So we look forward to meeting you,
either online or in person.
Goodbye for now.
>> Thank you.